[Applause]
primo was the work of dozens of artists
and engineers many of whom are here
tonight and the Academy is proud to
present a technical achievement award to
alex powell jason rising martin watt and
alex wells for their contributions to
the primo character animation system
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you
those who dream by day see things which
escape those who dream only by night our
dream was to create software so advanced
and transparent that it allows our
animators to work at the speed of their
imagination
primo was a monumental effort with
hundreds of hands touching this project
none of this would be possible without
the combined effort of animators
character riggers pipeline and the
talented engineering team of DreamWorks
and Intel I'd like to thank the the
animation team next we pull up sorry I'd
like to thank the animation team
Rex grin yawn jason Schleifer Fred
Nilsson Simon Otto Cassidy Curtis and
Dave tourists their guidance and
patience was essential to the design of
our leading edge animation workflows we
want to thank the technology leaders who
orchestrated the success of this project
especially bill Blue Boys fan I and Paul
de Lorenzo
we also want to thank Lincoln Wallen
Jill hopper and Jeff Wieck and all of
our studio executives for giving us a
chance to show that animation software
can transcend being a tool and delight
and enchant our users I'd like to thank
my parents for their sacrifice in the
insight the first sit me down in front
of a computer when I was just a few
years old and I'd also like to thank my
beautiful wife Bridget for her endless
support our stars collided brighter and
now we shine brighter together I love
you always and forever and finally thank
you to the wives and families of these
gentlemen standing up here with me
[Applause]